Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Marcus, James, Rachel, Kevin, Lily, Mark. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
We're here to ratify the ADR from the 19th: standard permissive license for code, Local Contexts labels plus community notice for TK skills, community review routing.
Before we ratify — Mark, you lodged a late objection in the channel. This is the room. Bring it.
Exactly.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Thank you. My objection is the external dependency on Local Contexts. If that project changes or disappears, our governance layer has a hole. That's real and I don't want it decided in a hallway.
That's the third time this has come back. I want to be honest that reopening a settled question a third time, without new information, is its own problem — it means we suppressed it rather than settled it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
That's fair.
So let's actually settle it. Mark, is there new information, or is it the same concern?
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Makes sense to me.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That tracks.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Sure, I can own that.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
Good point — let's do that.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
It's the same concern, stated in the open this time. I'll grant that.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Let's confirm in the channel.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Yeah, exactly.
Hang on, let me pull that doc up on my end. One sec.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Makes sense to me.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Just flagging that this touches licensing and the ADR, so loop me in when it firms up.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah, exactly.
Let's confirm in the channel.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Sure, I can own that.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Sure — one sec.
Good — next.
Then let's decide it for real, with a mitigation instead of a reopening.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Proposal: adopt the labels, AND we snapshot the label definitions into our own repo so a dependency change can't silently break us, AND we review the dependency annually. Mark, does the mitigation address the substance of your objection?
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Makes sense to me.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Right, that's what I meant.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to licensing and the ADR anyway.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Good point — let's do that.
It does. With the snapshot and the annual review, I can commit to this. Genuinely commit, not just stop arguing.
Got it.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Good point — let's do that.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Right, that's what I meant.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
That's fair.
Okay, works for me.
Just flagging that this touches licensing and the ADR, so loop me in when it firms up.
Then we ratify, with the mitigation. And we note: this is closed. If it comes back, it needs new information, not the same concern in a new venue.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Yeah, exactly.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Sure, I can own that.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Agreed. And for the record — that's what settling a conflict looks like versus suppressing it. Everyone said their piece, the objector committed, and we wrote down what would reopen it.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Right.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Right, that's what I meant.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Sure, I can own that.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
One thing: how does this affect the community review and the advisory process timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the licensing and the ADR timeline?
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Mark has the follow-up on licensing and the ADR — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
James has the follow-up on community review and the advisory process — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.